ON THE ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY'S
COMMITTEE ON AGING AND LONG TERM
CARE WILL NOW START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE I'LL TURN OVER THE
GAVEL. TO MR VOEPEL AND I WILL
GO AHEAD AND START PRESENTING
UNTIL OTHER OTHER OFFERS.
JOIN US AND THEN AT THAT POINT.
MR VOEPEL WILL CONTINUE --
CHAIRING THE COMMITTEE WHILE I
HAVE TO PRESENT A BILL IN IN
ANOTHER COMMITTEE SO.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR PUT ME TO
WORK TODAY.
I DON'T NUMBER FOUR EIGHT BE.
ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN GO AHEAD
INSTEAD OF THE BATTLE OF THE
PRESENT OKAY YOU GET A PRESENT
THE OTHER OKAY.
SO ITEM ONE AB.%
FIVE SIXTY SEVEN MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS IN TWENTY THIRTY THIS
PROJECTED CALIFORNIANS OVER THE
AGE OF SIXTY FIVE WILL BECOME A
LARGER SHARE OF THE POPULATION
THE CHILDREN UNDER.
EIGHTEEN MORE THAN HALF OF THIS
POPULATION ON THE LONG TERM CARE
SERVICES AT SOME POINT THEIR
LIVES.
YET THERE IS NO SINCE
SUSTAINABLE OPTION -- FOR
SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
COGNITIVE OR PHYSICAL
DISABILITIES TO OBTAIN
AFFORDABLE LONG TERM CARE
SERVICES MIDDLE CLASS SENIORS.
AND PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES
MUST DECIDE WHETHER TO SPEND
DOWN THEIR ASSETS IN ORDER TO
QUALIFY FOR MEDI CAL OR EXHAUST
THEIR PERSONAL ASSETS FOR PRE
PAYING FOR PRIVATE CARE.
THAT'S WHY I'M OFFERING THIS
BILL SB -- FIVE SIXTY SEVEN IT
ESTABLISHES A LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE TASK FORCE.
CAN VIENEN BY THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER THE PURPOSE OF THE
TASK FORCES TO PROVIDE EXPERT
RECOMMENDATIONS INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR.
IN ON THE COMPONENTS NECESSARY
TO ESTABLISH A STATEWIDE LONG
TERM CARE INSURANCE PROGRAM IN
CALIFORNIA.
GIVEN THE GUARD GROWING
RECOGNITION OF CALIFORNIA'S
DEMOGRAPHIC SHIPS IT IS AN
OPPORTUNE TIME TO IDENTIFY
STRATEGIES AVAILABLE TO JUST TO
CHART. SIX OF SIX A SUCCESSFUL
PATH TO LONG TERM CARE
SUSTAINABILITY -- I VERY MUCH
YOU THIS IS A LITTLE MILLENNIAL
ISSUE MY FAMILY WAS
UNFORTUNATELY ONE OF THE
FAMILIES IT WAS REALLY HARD HIT.
BY THE RECESSION AND BECAUSE OF
THAT THEY HAD TO SPEND DOWN ALL
OF THEIR RETIREMENT SECURITY TO
TRY THAT.
YEAH KEEP THE BUSINESS AFLOAT
AND KEEP THEIR HOME WELL THAT
RECESSION LASTED TOO LONG THEY
WEREN'T ABLE TO DO THAT SO NOT
ONLY DID I LOSE A BUSINESS THEY
ALSO HOME SO -- THERE'S NO
RETIREMENT SECURITY FOR THEM SO
THAT FALLS ON MYSELF AND OUR
OTHER IT AND MY SIBLINGS -- TO
TAKE ON THAT RESPONSIBILITY
BECAUSE THAT THEY ARE.
THEY DON'T HAVE THAT LONG TERM
CARE INSURANCE -- NOR THE
FINANCIAL STABILITY THAT THEY
ONCE HAD FOR WHEN THEY RETIRE SO --
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE GET THIS
RIGHT -- THERE ARE LESS
PROVIDERS NOW THAN THERE USED TO
BE THERE USED TO BE OVER HOW TO
PROVIDE AS A LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE NOW THERE'S YOU KNOW
AROUND TEN PROVIDERS OF LONG
TERM CARE INSURANCE WHICH ALSO --
DRIVES UP THE COST BECAUSE
THERE'S NOT AS MANY PROVIDER SO --
WE NEED TO COME UP WITH A BETTER
ALTERNATIVE TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
PROVIDING THE RETIREMENT
SECURITY THROUGH LONG TERM CARE
INSURANCE AND IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
FIGURES THIS OUT OF THIS TASK
FORCE IS GOING TO HELP US GET TO
WHERE WE NEED TO BE IN BECAUSE
OF THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND WITH ME HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS CAROL.
SCHOOL FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ON AGING.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
THERE ARE NONE.
WE APPRECIATE -- MISTER CALDERON
BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- THIS IS
THE ONE OF A NUMBER OF ISSUES
ADDRESSING THE HUGE -- HURDLE WE
FACE IN THE STATE OVER LONG TERM
CARE.
AND HOW TO PAY FOR IT -- THERE
HAVE BEEN EFFORTS TO THE
PARTNERSHIP FOR LONG TERM CARE
TO LOOK AT A PROGRAM THAT IS.
LONG NOT FUNCTIONING IN THE
STATE THIS WOULD BE A FOLLOW ON
TO THAT THAT WOULD.
BRING THE BRING THE DISCUSSION
TO THE LEVEL OF THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE.
BRINGING IN -- PEOPLE FROM THE
INDUSTRY BRINGING IN EXPERTS. TO
REALLY ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF HOW
DO WE CREATE A PRIVATE LONG TERM
SHOULD LONG TERM CARE INSURANCE
MARKET.
THAT IS AFFORDABLE THAT IS
ACCESSIBLE AND THAT ADDRESSES
NEEDS OF PEOPLE.
ON A ON ONGOING BASIS IN THE
STATE -- WE CURRENTLY HAVE MEDI
CAL THE COVERS PEOPLE WHO ARE --
IMPOVERISHED THEIR WORDS ARE
VERY FEW OPTIONS FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN THE MIDDLE CLASS -- THERE
IS AN EFFORT THROUGH -- THE
SENATE -- SB FIVE TWELVE TO
CREATE A STRUCTURE. TO LOOK AT
TO CREATING A STATEWIDE
INSURANCE PLAN THAT'S A
DIFFERENT BALLGAME THAN THIS
THAT IS A STEP ALONG THE WAY
THAT WE HOPE EVENTUALLY WILL
CREATE A STATE WIDE PROGRAM.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME THIS BRINGS
THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER'S
OFFICE TO BEAR TO REALLY FOCUS
ON THE ISSUE OF WHAT IS
AVAILABLE IN THE MARKET HERE
WHAT DO WE NEED TO DO TO CREATED
ACCEPTABLE AN ACCESSIBLE.
PRODUCT FOR PEOPLE SO WE ARE
DRIVE VOTE.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM NOBODY RIGHT.
THIS IS A ASSEMBLYMEMBERS -- I
HAVE A COUPLE COMMENTS ONE IS I
VOTED NO ON THIS IN THE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE.
GAY.
SO I JUST WANT TO LET YOU KNOW.
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT IT AND VOTE
YES TODAY I TELL YOU WHY BECAUSE
I'M LOOKING AT A REPORT BY JULY
SECOND IN YOUR THIS YOU KNOW
NEXT YEAR.
OF SO THIS IS NOT ANOTHER LAYER
OF BUREAUCRACY OR ANYTHING THIS
IS A FOCUS IS THE WAY I'M
LOOKING AT IT SO I READ THE BILL
WILL BE CLOSER.
JUST SO YOU KNOW THANK YOU -- I
WAS LICENSE FOR INSURANCE FOR
THIRTY NINE YEARS.
AND WAS LICENSED TO SELL LONG
TERM CARE.
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO SELL IN
TODAY'S MARKET BECAUSE THE
PREMIUMS AS YOU WELL POINTED OUT
ARE SO HIGH.
PEOPLE CAN'T SEE THE BENEFIT FOR
SOMETHING THAT MAY OR MAY NOT
HAPPEN SO THEY JUST DON'T BUY
THIS STUFF.
SO HOW WE ENSURE PEOPLE
HOPEFULLY THIS TASK FORCE WILL
COME UP WITH [inaudible]
SO.
THERE'S NO ROLL CALL YET WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM WERE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
SO I GUESS THAT'S ABOUT IT RIGHT
[inaudible]
IT'S JUST.
WELL I UNDERSTAND YOU GUYS ARE
OPERATING IN A SUBCOMMITTEE BUT
I APPRECIATE YOUR ALL YOUR TIME
AND WHEN THE BILL IS READY TO BE
HEARD BECAUSE THERE'S A QUORUM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR A OF AYE
VOTE.
YES SIR THANK YOU MEMBERS WILL
HOLD EVERYTHING OPEN
[inaudible]
ALL THE AT THE
ALTHOUGH THE
GOVERNMENT'S
[inaudible]
YES -- I AM YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
CHECK IT OUT -- IT'S STRONGER
[inaudible]
YEAH.
THANKS FOR SIGNING
.
I'LL TRY AND PLOW THROUGH
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MISTER CHAIR WE NOW HAVE A
QUORUM SO WE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
PRESIDENT [inaudible]
VOEPEL.
HORNER HARD ROCK [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
REYES [inaudible]
RUBIO.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB ELEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN
THIS AREA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF AB
ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN IS AN EFFORT
TO UPDATE AND MODERNIZE THE
OLDER CALIFORNIANS ACT WHICH IS
NOT BEEN UPDATED SINCE THE
NINETEEN NINETIES.
CONSEQUENTLY IT'S STILL A
CONTAINS SEVERAL OUTDATED
SECTIONS AND INCLUDES LANGUAGE
THAT NEEDS UPDATING TO REFLECT.
THE CHANGING PARADIGMS IN
SERVICE DELIVERY AND EFFORTS TO
SERVE OLDER CALIFORNIANS.
THIS IS A WORK IN PROGRESS AND
MANY -- AND MAY POSSIBLY BE A
BECOME A TWO YEAR BILL AS OF
TODAY AB ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING
TO PROVIDE AREA AGENCIES ON
AGING THE FLEXIBILITY TO DEVELOP
AND MANAGE PROGRAMS BASED ON
LOCAL NEED.
WHICH INCLUDES PROVIDING BLOCK
GRANTING OF FUNDS FOR THE OF FOR
THE ALZHEIMER'S DAYCARE RESOURCE
CENTERS THE BROWN BAG PROGRAM
THE FOSTER GRANDPARENT PROGRAM.
THE LINKAGES PROGRAM THE RESPITE
PROGRAM AND THE SENIOR COMPANION
PROGRAMS.
IT ALSO REPEALS THE SENIOR
CENTER BOND ACT OF NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR THE WHICH PROVIDED
FOR THE SALE OF GENERAL
OBLIGATION BONDS -- THE PROCEEDS
OF WHICH WERE TO BE USED UPON
APPROPRIATION BY THE LEGISLATURE
FOR SENIOR CENTERS FOR EXPANSION
OF SENIOR CENTER PROGRAMS.
WITH ME IS -- MISTER KELLS SHOE
IS ON HIS WAY.
YES THEY DID [inaudible]
THEY DID.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S A GOOD START [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH.
WE HAVE A WITNESS COMING IN.
IF I'M -- SURE GO AHEAD.
AND YOUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WORKING ON UPDATED WITH YOUR MOM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BOUCHER THE SUPPORT.
YEAH SUPPORT [inaudible]
FOR YEAH.
THAT IS A PRIMARY OKAY YEAH.
THE LAST.
THIRTY SEVEN IN ORDER TO KEEP UP
WITH SURGERY THAT'S OKAY WE KEEP
YOU HOPPING PLEASE.
YES MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE.
TERREL COACH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF AGENCIES ON AGING.
HARRY AGENCIES ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR A MINISTRY NHà HAVE A
VARIETY OF STATE AND FEDERAL
PROGRAMS.
AIMED AT PROVIDING SERVICES TO
KEEP OLDER ADULTS AT HOME.
AND IN THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT.
SOME OF THE PROGRAMS ARE
PROVIDED IN THAT YOU MOST
PROBABLY HAVE HEARD OF HIS LAKE
NUTRITION.
PROGRAMS CONGREGATE MEALS MEALS
ON WHEELS -- HEALTH INSURANCE
COUNSELING.
HUMBERT'S MEN PROGRAM THESE ARE
BILLS THAT I KNOW THAT YOU'VE
HEARD OF IN.
PROBABLY FAMILIAR IN YOUR
DISTRICT.
ALTHOUGH MOST OF THE FUNDING FOR
AGING SERVICES IS FEDERAL.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY THE STATE
DIDN'T ACT IN ORDER CALIFORNIANS
ACT.
WHICH WE REFER TO AS THE CA.
AND CALIFORNIA'S SPECIFIC
PROGRAMS SERVING OLDER ADULTS IN
THEIR HOMES COMPUTE COMMUNITIES.
WITH THE ELIGIBILITY BASED
PRIMARILY ON H..
NOT NECESSARILY I NEED.
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY THE
LEGISLATURE HAS -- AMENDED THE
ORDER CALIFORNIANS ACT --
SEVERAL TIMES. TO REFLECT
CHANGING POPULATION AND EMERGING
TO SERVICE DELIVERY NEEDS.
DESPITE THESE AMENDMENTS THE X.
STILL CONTAINS SEVERAL OUTDATED
SECTIONS -- WITH LANGUAGE THE
NEEDS UPDATING TO REFLECT THE
CHANGING MODELS AND SERVICE
DELIVERY.
NOW KEEP IN MIND MOST OF THE OCA
PROGRAMS TO NOT RECEIVE STATE
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT.
AND SOME HAVE.
THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE IN THE ACT
HAVEN'T BEEN IMPLEMENTED BECAUSE
THERE IS A LACK OF RESOURCES.
SEE FOR A FEELS AT THIS TIME THE
PARAMETERS THAT OVER AMERICAN
ACT HIS.
NEEDS TO BE UPDATED TO REFLECT
CURRENT VALUES AND PRIORITIES.
AND WE ASK THAT.
LOOK FAVORABLY UPON THIS BILL.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY I HAVE A MOTION BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO AS SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY ANY LAST
[inaudible]
WORDS [inaudible]
I'D.
GENERAL SUPPORT.
AT YES AB LEASE A COMMON
CALIFORNIA AT LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION AB ONE OF
THE PRIMARY FUNCTIONS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING IS TO CREATE
A PLAN.
AND THAT PLAN IS FILLED WITH A
LOT OF CHARTS AND AND GIVES LOTS
OF DATA TO THE STATE.
BUT THAT ONE SECTION OF COST
CONTAINMENT MEANS THAT THE PLAN
DOESN'T ACTUALLY GIVE SPECIFICS
FOR WHAT THE STATE CAN DO.
OR WHAT THE STATE SHOULD DO.
BECAUSE THEY CAN ONLY DO WHAT.
THEY THEY CAN ONLY PROPOSED THAT
WHICH IS CURRENTLY IN COST
CONTAINMENT.
IT'S IT'S IT'S SILLY TO HAVE A
PLAN THAT'S FULL OF ALL THIS
DATA.
IF THEY CAN'T GIVE A
RECOMMENDATION SO.
THANK THE AUTHOR.
FOR GIVING THE CALIFORNIA THE
TOOLS TO USE CDA PROPERLY.
GOOD AFTERNOON SUSAN TO MORRIS
ON BEHALF OF THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION WE SUPPORT THE CALM
CONCEPT AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE UP.
CRISTINA MILLS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA FOUNDATION FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AS
OF THE TWENTY EIGHT INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
MAJORITY OF THEM ARE NOW SERVING
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES OVER
THE AGE OF SIXTY FIVE WE DO
BELIEVE THAT IT'S TIME TO
MODERNIZE THE OLDER AMERICANS
ACT.
HI ANA ACTON WITH FREED WE WORK
IN CLOSE PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR
AREA AGENCY ON AGING.
AND IN FACT AS AN INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTER OVER 75% OF OUR
CONSUMERS ARE OLDER ADULTS WE
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN THIS AREA.
HI IS THERE IN AYE VOEPEL AYE
VOEPEL AYE WARNER HARD ROCK
[inaudible]
KALRA.
HI KALRA I LACKEY I'M LUCKY I
REYES [inaudible]
LOT RUBIO.
WHY THE MEASURE PASSES?
IT WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
MEMBERS WHO HAVE TOP OF THE I
WAS TESTIFYING IN THIS CASE.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE A. B..
TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AB TWELVE EIGHTY
SEVEN REQUIRES THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF REHABILITATION.
HEALTH CARE SERVICES AND SOCIAL
SERVICES TO DEVELOP A PLAN AND
STRATEGY FOR A FEAST STATEWIDE
IMPLEMENTATION OF A NO WRONG
DOOR.
SYSTEM THAT ASSISTS OLDER ADULTS
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND
CARE GIVERS IN OBTAINING
ACCURATE INFORMATION AND TIMELY
REFERRALS TO APPROPRIATE
COMMUNITY SERVICES AND SUPPORTS.
A. B. TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN ALSO
REQUIRES THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
UNIVERSAL ASSESSMENT TOOL AND
PROCESS TO STREAMLINE ACCESS TO
SERVICES THROUGH A COORDINATED
ASSESSMENT PROCESS.
AND REQUIRES BY JULY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE AS PART OF
THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY --
TO SUBMIT A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE REGARDING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE UNIVERSALIST
ASMAN TOOL ALONG WITH A TIMELINE
FOR IMPLEMENTATION.
MANY OLDER ADULTS PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES
SPACE DIFFICULTY AND ASSESSING.
ACCESSING AND SERVICE ACCESS IN
I'M SORRY FACE DIFFICULTY IN.
ACCESSING THE SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS THEY NEED TO LIVE ON
THEIR OWN TERMS AND IN THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT.
THEY OFTEN DON'T KNOW WHERE TO
TURN OR UP FOR HELP OR TO FIND
THE SERVICES THEY NEED.
THE PROBLEM IS MULTI FACETED AND
STEMS FROM A NUMBER OF FACTORS
FOR EXAMPLE -- AT THE STATE
LEVEL DEPARTMENTS OPERATE IN A
FRAGMENTED FASHION OFTEN WITH
LITTLE DATA SHARING AND POLICY
DEVELOPMENT ACROSS PROGRAMS THIS
RECOMMENDATION IMPACTS THE
ABILITY. TO DELIVER SERVICES TO
OUR SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITY.
THE GROWTH OF THE AGING
POPULATION WILL ONLY WORSEN AND
THE NEXT DECADE OF THESE
CHALLENGES BY DEVELOPING A NO
WRONG DOOR SYSTEM.
WE ENSURE THAT OUR SENIORS
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND
THEIR FAMILIES RECEIVE THE
SERVICES THAT THEY DESPERATELY
NEED [inaudible] SEVEN GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MIMES BLAKE JOHNSON WHO
BEHALF OF TEACHERS ARE FEELING
AMMA WHO THE PROUD SPONSOR OF AB --
TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN I LIKE TO
THINK THAT SOMEONE IS THERE IN
FOR THESE IT WAS ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
AND THIS IS A PERSONAL FOR
STATES HAS A FEW ANA SHE
EXPERIENCE FIRST HAND MANY
CHALLENGES WHEN CAME FOR MOTHER
AND A FATHER.
AT THE PRIMARY CARE GIVER -- SHE
FUNDS OF STRUGGLING TO ACCESS
WHAT THEY NEEDED.
OFTEN PLACING SEVERAL CALLS TO
HELP YET WITHOUT KNOWLEDGE OF
WHETHER SHE WAS GETTING WHAT
THEY NEEDED -- CALIFORNIA'S
AGING AND DISABILITY RESOURCE
CONNECTION PROGRAMS OFFER
SOLUTION SOME OF THESE PROBLEMS
PROVIDING INFORM ASSISTANCE TO
OLDER ADULTS WITH DISABILITIES
AND FAMILIES.
WHEN INFORMATION COUNSELING AND
SERVICE COORDINATION TO HELP
PEOPLE ACCESS WHAT THEY NEED
WHEN THEY NEED IT?
UNFORTUNATELY THIS MARS
AVAILABLE IN ONLY EIGHT COUNTIES
AS PART OF THE MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING AB TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN
CALLS ON THE STATE TO DEVELOP A
STRATEGY. FOR STATEWIDE
IMPLEMENTATION.
INCREASING CALIFORNIA'S EARLY IN
THIS OF DISABLED RESIDENTS
QUALITY OF LIFE SHOULD BE A TOP
PRIORITY FOR THE STATE AND FOR
THESE REASONS.
ARE STRICTLY EFFORT I BOTH AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
HELLO CRISTINA MILLS CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS THIS IS ONE OF
OUR PRIORITY BILLS FOR THIS YEAR
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CAN I THIS IS ON ACTIVE AND
FREED COULD I HAVE A FEW MINUTES
AS AN EXPERT WITNESS POTENTIALLY
TO TALK ABOUT THIS.
NO LONGER BILL.
OR DO I JUST GET A MINUTE OR
LESS TWO MINUTES OKAY.
SO AGAIN -- THIS IS A BILL THAT
I'M VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT --
FREE IS ONE OF TWENTY
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
PROVIDING SERVICES TO PEOPLE
REGARDLESS OF AGE AND TYPE OF
DISABILITY.
AND WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS
KIND OF ART NO WRONG DOOR SYSTEM
ON A LOCAL LEVEL. FOR MANY YEARS
WE HAVE THE AGING -- AND
DISABILITY RESOURCE CONNECTION
OF NEVADA COUNTY IT'S A
PARTNERSHIP.
BETWEEN THE AGENCY ON AGING AREA
FOR AND FREED AND ABOUT ELEVEN
EXTENDED PARTNERS FROM HOSPICE.
OF THE FOOT HILLS TO OUR COUNTY
ADULT SERVICES TO MEDICAL --
FQHC HEALTH CLINICS.
AND IT'S REALLY IS A GOOD
EXAMPLE OF A NO WRONG DOOR
SYSTEM -- FOR CALIFORNIANS FOR
PEOPLE TO ACCESS SERVICES THIS
IS SOMETHING I'M PASSIONATE
ABOUT NOT JUST ON A PROFESSIONAL
LEVEL BUT A PERSONAL LEVEL.
I WAS INJURED IN A CAR ACCIDENT
AT AGE FOURTEEN IF IT WASN'T FOR
THE LOCAL INDEPENDENT LIVING
CENTER TO HELP MY FAMILY
NAVIGATE.
THE BENEFITS AND THE SERVICES
THAT I NEEDED IT WOULD IT IT'S
REALLY SCARY I LIKE TO SAY THAT
PEOPLE YOU KNOW WHEN HE FIRST
ENTERED DISABILITY THEY HAVE NO
IDEA WHERE TO GO.
AND THE SAME WITH AGING FOR
THOSE OF US WHO AID FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN OUR LIVES RIGHT WE
HAVE NO IDEA WHAT RESOURCES ARE
OUT THERE.
AND MORE RECENTLY IN DECEMBER MY
FATHER PASSED AWAY AND MY MOM
WAS THE PRIMARY CARE GIVER FOR
TWO YEARS.
BEING SOMEONE WHO IS VERY
FAMILIAR WITH LPS HAS SYSTEMS.
IT WAS DIFFICULT TO NAVIGATE
RIGHT EVEN ON A PERSONAL LEVEL
FOR MY FAMILY.
SO WE WORK TOGETHER TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO A BROAD ARRAY OF
SERVICES AND CONTINUE OF HELP IN
ACCESSING SERVICES WE DO THIS
WORK ON A LOCAL LEVEL TO NOT
ONLY STREAMLINED ACCESS TO L.
TSS REDUCE DUPLICATION.
WE LEVERAGE LIMITED RESOURCES
AND WE IDENTIFY GAPS IN SERVICES
AT A LOCAL LEVEL -- BUT WE
REALLY ARE IN NEED OF STATEWIDE
CONSISTENCY FOR IMPLEMENTATION
OF NO LONGER SYSTEMS ON THE
LOCAL LEVEL.
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
NEED SIMILAR SERVICES AS OLDER
ADULTS THERE'S REALLY THIS
FUNCTIONAL NEED PEACE THAT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT REGARDLESS OF
AGE PEOPLE NEED ACCESS TO THE
SAME KIND OF SERVICES.
AND THERE ARE THE SYSTEMS ARE SO
SILO THEY'RE SO DIFFICULT TO
NAVIGATE -- THAT WE REALLY NEED
TO LOOK AT SYSTEMS ALIGNMENT AND
THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING. THREE
NO WRONG DOOR AND LOOKING TO SEE
IF WE CAN INCENTIVIZE WAYS FOR
LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS TO WORK
TOGETHER ON THE LOCAL LEVEL TO
ACCESS TELL PEOPLE ACCESS
SERVICES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AMY BLOOMBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
FACILITIES REPRESENTING NINE
HUNDRED SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES AND FOREIGN AND FIFTY
INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITIES IN
THE STATE.
AND STRONG SUPPORT WE THINK THIS
WILL BE A REALLY INVALUABLE TOOL
FOR PATIENTS AND FAMILIES AND
CAREGIVERS.
GOOD AFTERNOON SUSAN TO MORRIS
ON BEHALF OF THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION A REPORT THAT CAME
OUT -- JUST LAST MONTH FOUND
THAT ONLY 16% OF SENIORS HAVE A
REGULAR COGNITIVE ASSESSMENT.
THIS BILL TAKES CARE OF TWO
THINGS ONE TOO MANY ASSESSMENTS
AND TO THAT WE'RE NOT ASKING THE
RIGHT QUESTIONS SO A UNIVERSAL
ASSESSMENT PROVIDES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SCREEN.
DETECT AND PREVENT --
A TREATMENT PLAN THANK YOU.
LISA COLEMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LONG TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
CRISTINA BOSS HAMILTON WITH YOU
W. ASKED ME A ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU -- MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN
ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA COUNTY
IN SUPPORT.
YES THERE -- KILLS WITH THE HAIR
AGENCIES ON AGING AND SUPPORT.
VERY WELL THANK YOU.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I HAVE A MOTION BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO AND A SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURNER **** BATH.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN NAZARIAN.
AYE MISSOURI NINE VOEPEL AYE.
AYE.
WARNER HARD ROCK.
WARNER HOME ROTH AYE KALRA.
AYE KALRA AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE REYES.
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE THE MEASURE PASSES.
IS IS UP.
SIX ONE YOUR SIX ZERO TWO YEAH
[inaudible]
THE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ACCORDING TO THE PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA
BY TWENTY THIRTY THE STATE'S
OVER SIXTY FIVE POPULATION WILL
INCREASE BY FOUR MILLION WHILE
ALSO BECOMING MORE RACIALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY DIVERSE.
FURTHER THE NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIANS FACING DIFFICULTIES
WITH SELF CARE WILL REACH OVER
ONE MILLION AND 88% INCREASE
FROM.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE THIS RAPID
AGING OF CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION
WILL IMPACT ALL AREAS OF THE
SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM.
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO WILL
ESTABLISH AS PART OF THE MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING A COMPREHENSIVE
STRATEGY FOR PREPARING AND
SUPPORTING CALIFORNIA'S PAID
PARA PROFESSIONAL AND
PROFESSIONAL WORKFORCE.
AS WELL AS THE UNPAID FAMILY
CARE GIVER WORKFORCE THIS BILL
RESPONSE TO NEEDS OF AN AGING
CALIFORNIA BY PROVIDING
RECOMMENDATIONS.
TO ESTABLISH AND SCALE THE WORK
FORCE DEMANDS OF HOME CARE
WORKERS.
INCREASING GERIATRIC RELATED
COMPETENCIES AND HEALTH CARE AND
BUILD OFF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
OUTLINED FOR THE CALIFORNIA TASK
FORCE FAMILY CARE GIVING.
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO IS A
PIECE OF A MULTI PACKAGE. TO
ESTABLISH THE CALIFORNIA MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING AND DIRECT
PRIORITIES FOR THE STATE TO
ADDRESS THE RAPIDLY INCREASING.
NEED.
I HAVE THREE RIVAL.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO BE VERY BRIEF --
AGAIN PLAY JOHNSON ABOUT STAGE
IS A FEW ON A MOCK -- PROUD TO
SPONSOR AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
AGAIN THIS IS BEEN SEES --
EXPERIENCE FIRST HAND ME THE
CHALLENGES SECURING FOR A MOTHER
AND FATHER.
AND SHE KNOWS THE IMPORTANCE --
ROLE THAT UNPAID CAREGIVERS WITH
PAY DIRECT CARE WORKERS PLAY IN
HELPING OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE
DISABILITIES LIVE WITH DIGNITY
AND RESPECT -- AB THURSDAY TO
THE POINT STEP IN IDENTIFYING
PLANNING FOR IN ADDRESSING THE
NEEDS OF THE WORK FORCE TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S CAN AID
WITH DIGNITY AND INDEPENDENCE.
FOR THESE REASONS I SPECIFICALLY
ASKED ONE AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME AND I THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY FOR
THE SHIPMENT SUPPORT ISSUE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SOME REMEMBER AS AARON
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS CHRISTINA BOSS HAMILTON
I HAVE THE PLEASURE OF
REPRESENTING YOU W. APPS ME WE
REPRESENT A HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND
I JUST AS WORKERS.
OUR INTEREST IN THIS BILL IS
VERY CLEAR -- OUR MEMBERSHIP ARE
PREDOMINANTLY A VERY LOW INCOME
WOMEN MOSTLY WOMEN OF COLOR WHO
PERFORM GOD'S WORK.
THEY TAKE CARE OF SENIORS AND
PEOPLE DISABILITIES FOR THE MOST
PART THEY ARE NOT TREATED WITH
THE RESPECT AND THE FRANKLY PAY
THE WAGES IN THE BENEFITS THAT
THEY DESERVE FOR THE IMPORTANT
WORK THAT THEY DO.
AND THIS BILL IS VERY SPECIFIC
TO NEEDING TO HAVE
PRIORITIZATION AND
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE PAID AND
UNPAID CARE GIVING WORK FORCE
AND I I WANT TO SAY I FEEL.
THAT THERE'S A CERTAIN CHANGE IN
THE AIR IN THE LEGISLATURE --
PERHAPS WITH THE NEW GOVERNOR
THERE IT SEEMS LIKE WE'RE
HITTING CRITICAL MASS NOW WHERE
THERE'S ACTUALLY A DESIRE TO PAY
ATTENTION TO THE ISSUES OF AGING
AND THE WORK FORCE THAT.
ACTUALLY ALLOWS PEOPLE TO REMAIN
AT HOME BECAUSE WE CAN SAY THAT
WE SUPPORT THAT.
BUT IF WE DON'T ACTUALLY PASSED
POLICIES THAT MAKE THAT HAPPEN
THEN YOU KNOW IT'S NEITHER HERE
NOR THERE SO THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP THANK YOU
TO THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU TO THE STATE TREASURER
AND THE OTHER FOLKS WHO'VE --
INDICATED THAT THAT THIS IS A
ISSUE THEY WANT TO CHAMPION
THANK YOU TO OUR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WHO HAVE IN THE PAST
CHAMPION THIS.
AND I I WANTED ONLY STRESS ONE
THING RELATIVE TO THE BILL IT
CALLS UPON THE NEED TO ESTABLISH
AN INDEPENDENT SUSTAINABLE
FINANCING FINANCING MECHANISM.
BECAUSE THE REALITY IS WE CAN'T.
DEAL WITH WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
UNLESS WE DEAL WITH HOW WE WILL
PAY THESE PEOPLE MORE MONEY WE
CAN SAY THAT THEY'RE WORTH MORE
MONEY.
BUT THE REALITY IS THAT MONEY
EITHER COMES FROM THE STATE
GOVERNMENT OR COMES OUT OF
PEOPLE'S POCKETBOOKS.
AND IT HAS TO DO WE HAVE TO
DEDICATE TIME AND IN A RESOURCES
INTO FIGURING OUT WHAT SOURCE OF
REVENUE IS ACTUALLY POSSIBLE.
IN THIS DAY POLITICALLY AND
POSSIBLY.
IN TERMS OF INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
WOULD NOT CONTINUE TO DURING THE
GENERAL FUND WHICH IS
ESSENTIALLY WHAT'S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW SO I JUST WANT.
TO LEAVE ON THAT NO AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
[inaudible]
WICKS.
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT GOOD
AFTERNOON SUSAN MORRIS ON BEHALF
OF THE ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSOR -- TWO POINT THREE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS ARE LIVING
WITH OR CARING FOR SOMEONE WITH
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE TODAY.
AND AN ESSENTIAL PILLAR OF ANY
STATE PLAN IS A FOCUS ON THE
WORK FORCE PAID AND UNPAID WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
LIZA COMMON CALIFORNIA LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
ANY BLOOMBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
FACILITIES IN SUPPORT WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY WOMAN FOR
INTRODUCING THIS BILL WORKFORCE
IS A CRITICALISSUE AND A AND A
KEY ELEMENT TO THE MASTER PLAN.
WORK FORCES THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE ONE THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE WHEN
INDIVIDUALS REACH A POINT WHERE
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO BE AT THEIR
HOME ANYMORE WE NEED TO HAVE
THAT APPROPRIATE WORK FOR
CERTIFIED NURSE ASSISTANTS AND
NURSES IN GENERAL. TO ADEQUATELY
STAFFED THE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY SO LOOK FOR TO WORKING
WITH YOU.
FRED MADE ON BEHALF OF CAL PACE
THE PROGRAM FOR ALL INCLUSIVE
CARE FOR THE ELDERLY WHO
REPRESENT THE FRAILES STE.
I SENIORS FIFTY FIVE YEARS AND
OLDER AND WERE -- IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
AGAIN MICHAEL RIGHT AGAIN ABOUT
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA
CLARA COUNTY SUPPORT.
NORMAN FRANKLIN A A RP VOLUNTEER.
ALL ON BEHALF OF THE THREE POINT
THREE MILLION CALIFORNIA --
MEMBERS OF A A RP WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE MASTER PLAN THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES AGAINST.
ANY COMMENTS AGAINST.
SERRA.
GETTING HERE A MOTION AND A
SECOND -- QUESTIONS.
AS WELL AS SOME FULLY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL BUT BEFORE IF I
WERE ON THE FENCE THEM THE
OUTFIT COORDINATION WOULD HAVE.
PUSHED ME OVER THE YEARS SIDE
THE NO WAY POLKA DOTS.
ANYWAY I AM OF THE BILL THANK
YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
SECOND PERFECT.
MISTER KALRA FOR A MINUTE MOTION.
MR BOERNER HORVATH SECOND THE
BILL OF OPEN THE ROLE.
I MAKE A LOT OF HELP AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO AS ARE A I'M SORRY
I'M SORRY.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE A FINAL I
JUST WANT ONE FINAL COMMENT I
WANT TO THINK -- YOU AS THE
CHAIRMAN -- AS WE ALL WORK
TOGETHER ON THIS PLAN THIS IS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO ALL OF US
AND I I'M REALLY DOING IT FOR
ALL THOSE FAMILIES ARE OUT THERE
RIGHT NOW.
THEY CAN'T FIND THE WORK FORCE
TO TAKE CARE OF OUR ELDERLY.
AND I WAS IN THAT SHOULD THOSE
SHOES JUST LIKE -- TREASURE MALL
WITH AN UNTIL THAT'S IN YOUR
FACE AND YOU DON'T UNDERSTAND
HOW MUCH YOU CANNOT FIND WORK
FORCE TRAIN PEOPLE THE YOUR
LOVED ONES CAN BE TAKEN CARE OF
THE YOU KNOW THAT THEY'RE SAFE --
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT AND SO I'M
HONORED TO BE A PART OF THIS
YEAH I WORKING ON THIS AGING
MASTER PLAN AND I'M LOOKING
FORWARD.
TO ALL MANY MORE CONVERSATIONS
ON GETTING THIS THING MOVING
FORWARD.
THANK YOU FOR THAT COMMENT
BECAUSE IN MY RUSH TO HURRY UP
ALONG AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
PROCESS IS BEING MET.
I DIDN'T EVEN MAKE A COMMENT I
VERY MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AS WELL AS WELL
AS OUR TREASURE FIONA AND I'M
PLEASED TO HAVE A TEAM OF
INDIVIDUALS.
WHO WHO HAVE ADVANCED THESE
BILLS AND HAVE BEEN
STRENGTHENING IN OVERTIME GIVEN
THE PRECEDING WORK -- PRIOR TO
THIS -- PRIOR TO THIS YEAR AS
WELL -- SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
EFFORTS LOOK FORWARD TO THE THE
THE COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS.
OUT WITH THAT LET'S CALL THE
ROLL.
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO THIS AREA
I IS ARE YOU I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE BURNER HARD ROCK. FOR
HER RENT I KALRA.
KALRA I LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE
REYES.
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE THE MEASURE PASSES.
THANK YOU VERY MAKE YOU VERY
MUCH.
SO WHY DON'T WE GO BACK AT WE
STARTED HEARING AB FIVE SIXTY
SEVEN AS A SUB COMMITTEE SO.
LET'S BRING THAT UP FOR A VOTE
AND GO THROUGH THE LIST OF BILLS
AT THIS POINT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MOVED BY MISTER KALRA SECOND BY
MISS RUBIO.
CALL THE ROLL.
SB FIVE SIXTY SEVEN NAZARIAN HI
MS ARE IN A HIGH VOEPEL.
I WARNER **** ROB.
ORDER HER VOTE I KALRA.
KALRA I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE REYES RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE THE MEASURE PASSES.
GOING -- TO ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR AB ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN THIS
AREA AND I DON'T KNOW IF THERE
WAS ANYONE WHO MISSED IT SO.
AB ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN BORDER
HORROCKS.
WARNER HER OR HER VOTE I ANY
ITEMS FIVE AND SIX EVERYONE WAS
HERE SO WE HAVE TWO MORE AUTHORS
A MISS REYES AND MISTER
OBERNOLTE -- AND AT THIS POINT I
WILL PASSED THE GAVEL BACK DOWN.
TO YOU.
SIR VICE CHAIR AND I WILL HEAD
OVER TO HUMAN SERVICES.
THAT IS RIGHT.
RIGHT
--
THE THE MASSIVE
FINANCES --
SEARCHES
[inaudible] FOR THIS IS -- G.
[inaudible]
CITY -- WE'LL [inaudible]
SEE [inaudible]
SENATE [inaudible]
YEAH
.
THE CHOICES WERE [inaudible]
YEAH.
OKAY.
A LOT [inaudible]
THE SHE SAID HARDWARE --
TOLERATING SHOULD SORT OF FILLER
MODEL NUMBER.
SHE SAID.
SOME ADDITIONAL -- THE SPEAKERS
ON THE OPERATION.
THIS -- ONE WE SHOULD SAY --
YEAH.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB FIVE SIXTY
EIGHT ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES MY
NEIGHBOR.
THANK YOU MY NEIGHBOR AND MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS -- I WANT TO
PRESENT TO YOU AB FIVE SIXTY
EIGHT WHICH CREATES THE
CALIFORNIA.
CARE COR.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE MORE THAN
FIVE POINT FIVE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE OVER SIXTY
FIVE YEARS OF AGE.
ACCORDING TO THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS NUMBER IS ONLY EXPECTED TO
DOUBLE IN THE NEXT TWELVE YEARS
THIS DEMOGRAPHIC REQUIRES A
VARIETY OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES.
THE FAMILY CARE GIVER ALLIANCE
ESTIMATES THAT ABOUT FOUR POINT
FOUR MILLION UNPAID FAMILY CARE
GIVERS.
OUR OUR PRESENT ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
AND APPROXIMATELY 40% OF THESE
CARE GIVERS ARE DIAGNOSED WITH
DEPRESSION.
AS NOTED BY THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION.
AND ONE IN FOUR OF THESE CARE
GIVERS ARE MILLENNIALS MANY OF
WHOM DROPPED OUT OF SCHOOL OR
FULL TIME EMPLOYMENT TO PROVIDE
CARE FOR FAMILY MEMBERS.
CALIFORNIA CARE CORE OUT TO
HOPES TO TACKLE BOTH THE WORK
FOR SHORTAGE FOR LONG TERM CARE
AS WELL AS PROVIDE RESPITE.
FOR UNPAID FAMILY CARE GIVERS
WHO DON'T HAVE ACCESS.
TO ON OF TO ON AFFORDABLE CARE.
THE CARE COR THE CALIFORNIA CARE
CORPS PROGRAM OPERATES AS A
YOUTH WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM HOUSED UNDER CAL BALLING
TEAR.
AND ADMINISTERED SIMILARLY TO
AMERICORPS.
IT WILL TRADE IN MATCH YOUTH TO
PROVIDE NON MEDICAL RESPITE CARE
IN ORDER TO ASSIST UNPAID FAMILY
CARE GIVERS.
GIVING THEM TIME AND FREEDOM TO
RETURN TO SCHOOL OR REENTER THE
WORKFORCE.
MY UP MY OFFICE HAS BEEN WORKING
CLOSELY WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND
HOPES TO CONTINUE TO DO SO TO
ENSURE THAT THE PROGRAM IS AS
SUCCESSFUL AS POSSIBLE AND TO
MITIGATE ANY UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. TO OTHER AGING AND
LONG TERM CARE PROGRAMS.
WITH ME TO SPEAK MORE ABOUT THE
NEED OF THIS PROGRAM.
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE PROGRAM UP
OF PROGRAM OPERATIONS OF
ALZHEIMER'S SAN DIEGO JESSICA
AND BEEN YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS JESSICA PENA AND I'M
THE VICE PRESIDENT PROGRAMS THAT
ALZHEIMER'S SAN DIEGO WE ARE A
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION DEDICATED
TO IMPROVING QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
FAMILIES THAT ARE LIVING WITH
DEMENTIA IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
ALL OF THE PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
WE PROVIDE OUR FREE BUT I'M
HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY TO TALK
TO YOU ABOUT ONE IN PARTICULAR.
FOR SOMEONE WITH DEMENTIA IS A
DIFFICULT AND DEMANDING JOB
FAMILIES NEED SUPPORT AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO STEP AWAY FROM
CARE RESPONSIBILITIES AND FOR
MANY.
THIS IS NOT EASY TO COORDINATE
AND THE COSTS INVOLVED CAN OFTEN
MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE.
WE SAW A REAL NEED IN OUR
COMMUNITY AND WANTED TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
ALSO COMPANIONS WAS CREATED TO
PROVIDE COMPANIONSHIP
SOCIALIZATION AND SUPERVISION
FOR PERSON LIVING WITH DEMENTIA
WHICH GIVES THEIR CARE GIVER THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR A BREAK AND FOR
MANY IT IS THE ONLY SOURCE OF
REST BUT THEY HAVE.
ALSO COMPANIONS IS THE ONLY
VOLUNTEER BASED IN HOME DEMENTIA
SPECIFIC RESPITE PROGRAM IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND ONE OF
ONLY A HANDFUL IN THE UNITED
STATES.
FAMILIES ALSO RECEIVE THROUGH
THIS PROGRAM AN IN HOME
ASSESSMENT GUIDANCE AND SUPPORT
FROM A SOCIAL WORKER AND A
VOLUNTEER WITH WHOM THEY CAN
BUILD A LONG TERM CONNECTION.
PAID RESPITE PROGRAMS ARE UNABLE
TO OFFER THIS LEVEL OF SUPPORT
TO FAMILIES THUS INCREASING THE
VALUE OF THIS TRULY ONE OF A
KIND MODEL.
SINCE LAUNCHING THE PROGRAM WE
HAVE PROVIDED NEARLY TWENTY
THOUSAND HOURS OF FREE RESPITE
TO THREE HUNDRED FAMILIES.
THE IMPACT HAS BEEN TREMENDOUS
AND WE SEE IT EVERY DAY IN
TALKING TO FAMILIES.
AS WELL AS THE FEEDBACK WE SEE A
PROGRAM EVALUATIONS. 94% OF CARE
GIVERS IN THE PROGRAM FEEL THEIR
STRESS HAS BEEN REDUCED. 99% SAY
THEY LOOK FORWARD TO THEIR
RESPITE BREAKS AND 1100% WOULD
RECOMMEND THE PROGRAM.
BUT THIS PROGRAM WOULD NOT BE
WHAT IT IS WITHOUT THE MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
VOLUNTEERS THAT HAVE BEEN A PART
OF IT.
THEY RANGE IN AGE FROM EIGHTEEN
TO EIGHTY ONE WITH 69% BEING
BETWEEN THE AGES OF EIGHTEEN AND
TWENTY NINE MANY ARE COLLEGE
STUDENTS PREPARING FOR CAREERS
IN HEALTH CARE PSYCHOLOGY AND
SOCIAL WORK.
AND HAVING THIS KIND OF
INTERGENERATIONAL ASPECT TO THE
PROGRAM WAS NOT EXACTLY
SOMETHING WE PLANNED BUT IT HAS
BEEN A WONDERFUL ELEMENT TO THE
PROGRAM.
DESPITE THE CONTINUED GROWTH OF
OUR ALSO COMPANIONS PROGRAM
THERE IS STILL SO MUCH NEED IN
THE COMMUNITY.
AB FIVE SIXTY EIGHT WILL PROVIDE
CARE GIVERS WITH ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT AND RESPITE WHILE ALSO
SERVING AS A YOUTH WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM.
ALZHEIMER'S SAN DIEGO IS PROUD
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL AND HOPES
YOU WILL DO THE SAME.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE THIS AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU COMMENTS IN SUPPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MONICA
MILLER REPRESENTING ALZHEIMER'S
LOS ANGELES AN ULTIMATE ORANGE
COUNTY AS WELL SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT TO THINKING OF GOOD
AFTERNOON SUSAN BORYS ON BEHALF
OF THE ALZHEIMER'S ASSOCIATION
WE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR VERY
MUCH FOR INTRODUCING THE BILL.
AND WERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY WAS
HERE TO IT.
WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT WORKFORCE
ISSUES BECAUSE THIS IS ONE OF
THE SOLUTIONS THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT JUST BEFORE YOUR ARRIVAL?
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
YEAH I JUST -- VERY EXCITED TO
HEAR THAT -- YOU HAVE A REMEDY
HERE THAT IT'S GOING.
TO YOUR COURAGE VOLUNTEERISM.
AS WELL AS BRIDGING THE GAP
BETWEEN THOSE BEGINNING AND
ENTERING THE WORK FORCE.
AN AGING POPULATION -- NOT ONLY
DOES IT DO THAT THOUGH BUT IT IT
GIVES THESE THESE PEOPLE WHO ARE.
VERY OVER TAXED WITH -- I DON'T
MEAN THAT FINANCIALLY.
BUT THE EMOTIONAL.
THE CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH
PROVIDING THIS CARE AND THE
WORRY.
AND THE DIFFICULTY WITH RUNNING
THEIR OWN LIVES.
AS WELL AS THOSE OF THEIR OWN
PARENTS AYE.
I HAD A SIMILAR EXPERIENCE WITH
MY OWN MOTHER FOR A PERIOD OF
TIME ALMOST A YEAR WHERE I
PROVIDED CARE FOR HER.
AND I COULD TELL YOU IT IS --
IT'S DIFFICULT AND EVEN THOUGH
YOU.
YOU'RE FILLED WITH LOVE FOR THEM
WHAT ONE RETURN THAT -- THE GIFT
THAT THEY PROVIDED.
YOU WHEN YOU WERE GROWING UP --
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT VERY VERY
DIFFICULT TO SO THIS IS A
BRILLIANT -- PROCESS AND SO
PROUD THAT -- USED TO BE A SMALL
PART OF IT SO WELL DONE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR BEING A PART OF IT.
COOPER [inaudible]
THANK.
AND MAY I HAVE A MOTION
[inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
SELECT.
SHE BEAT YOU OUT.
QUESTION I WILL [inaudible]
SO.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE YOUR SITE.
KNOWING THAT WE HAVE SO MANY OF
THE MOST VULNERABLE SENIORS THAT
WE NEED TO TAKE CARE OF AND WE
HAVE UNPAID CARE GIVERS.
THEY NEED A LITTLE HELP AND THIS
IS A GREAT IDEA TO HELP THOSE.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE.
SB.
FIVE SIX EIGHT NAZARIAN.
VOEPEL.
I VOEPEL FIVE BOERNER HORVATH.
I KALRA.
KALRA AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY HIGH RADIUS HI RES I
RUBIO.
RUBIO WHY THE MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU
-- ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
AB THIRTY NINETY SIX MISTER
OBERNOLTE THANK YOU MISTER TERRY
LOOK GOOD WITH THAT GAVEL.
SO -- I DON'T HAVE TO EXPLAIN TO
THIS COMMITTEE THE TREMENDOUS
PROBLEM THAT ELDER ABUSE IS IN
CALIFORNIA -- I WAS VERY
SURPRISED TO FIND THAT ONE IN
TEN ELDERS IN THE STATE.
HAS SUFFERED ELDER ABUSE IT OUT
I WAS SHOCKED TO DISCOVER THAT.
ONLY ABOUT ONE IN FOURTEEN CASES
OF ELDER ABUSE EVEN GETS
REPORTED SO -- CALIFORNIA NOW
HAS THE HIGHEST RATE OF ELDER
ABUSE OF ANY STATE IN THE
COUNTRY.
WHICH I FIND ASTONISHING AND
IT'S JUST GOING TO GET WORSE
BECAUSE OUR ELDER POPULATION IS
GOING TO MORE THAN DOUBLE BY THE
YEAR -- TWENTY TWENTY SIX THIS
BILL AB THIRTEEN NINETY SIX IS A
STE IN A SMALL WAY SEEKS TO DEAL
WITH THAT PROBLEM IT.
ALLOWS A JUDGE TO IMPOSE.
A CLINICAL COUNSELING OR ANGER
MANAGEMENT CLASSES ON A BATTERER
WHEN ISSUING AID -- ELDER ABUSE
RESTRAINING ORDER JUDGES ALREADY
HAVE THAT DISCRETION WHEN
ISSUING A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDER I THINK IT
MAKES GREAT SENSE TO ALLOW THEM
THAT DISCRETION.
WHEN -- ISSUING A ELDER ABUSE
RESTRAINING ORDER ANYTHING THAT
WE CAN DO TO TRY AND LOWER.
THIS -- INCIDENTS OF ELDER ABUSE
AND GET OUT OF THE ON TO STERN
THIS POSITION OF HAVING MORE
ELDER ABUSE THAN ANY STATE IN
THE COUNTRY I THINK WOULD BE A
GOOD THING.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
DO ALONG HAVE THE COVERS A
CALIFORNIA BAR ASSOCIATION WHERE
THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
THIS BILL COMES -- FROM ACTUALLY
SOME PROBATE JUDGES AN ORANGE
COUNTY.
WHO NOTICE THAT?
THEY HAD MANY OF THE SAME NEEDS
THAT -- THEIR COUNTERPARTS IN
THE FAMILY LOVE BENCH HAD IN
TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO CRAFT AN
APPROPRIATE SOLUTION.
TO ABUSE BUT DIDN'T HAVE THE
TOOLS.
AND THAT'S WHAT AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY SIX IS ALL ABOUT WE'RE
TRYING TO EXTEND.
THE FLEXIBILITY SO THAT THE
JUDGES ON THE PROBATE PENSION OR
THE IN IN TAKING CARE OF THE
ELDER ABUSE CASES.
HAVE THE TOOLS AVAILABLE TO TRY
TO CRAFTED APPROPRIATE SOLUTION
TO PUT AN END TO VIOLENCE AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT.
JEFF CHARTED YEAR -- PUBLIC A
SHOULD WE SAY THAT HAVE TWO KIDS.
AND HERE FOR CARE AS FAR AS FOR
SENIORS SO WE SPREE BE IN
SUPPORT HERE.
HI ANDY LEAVING BOMB ON BEHALF
OF JUDICIAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA AND UNFORTUNATELY THE
BILL IS OUTSIDE OF OUR PURVIEW
SO I CAN'T GIVE IT A ROUSING
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR YOUR
GREAT.
WORK AND TO LET YOU KNOW THERE A
COUPLE OF PROVISIONS THAT
IMPLICATE THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
IN THE BILL WE HAVE SOME OF
FRUSTRATION OVER THEM BUT IT'S A
MINOR ITS MODEST FOR WORKING
WITH THE OFFICE WERE REALLY
REALLY HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO DO SO
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION.
COME ANSWER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
YES MA'AM.
I HAD ONE QUESTION -- THIS
MANDATORY CLINICAL COUNSELING OR
ANGER MANAGEMENT WITH THE
SUPPLIED TO BOTH TEMPORARY
RESTRAINING ORDERS AND PERMANENT
RESTRAINING ORDERS.
JUST TO BE CLEAR THIS IS NOT
MANDATORY IT'S LEFT TO THE
DISCRETION OF THE JUDGE WHETHER
OR NOT TO IMPOSE IT -- MR DOOR
OKAY ANSWERED IF IT'S APPLIES
TEMPORARY AS WELL I WOULD THINK
IT WOULD.
YES I BELIEVE IN HIM POINTS TO
BOTH.
AND A I THINK NOT YEAH YEAH
KEVIN COULD GO BEYOND THE EXTENT
OF THE RESTRAINING ORDER.
BUT IT DOES APPLY IN ALL CASES --
THE IDEA IS JUST SOMETHING TO
TRY TO PROVIDE -- THE TREATMENT
IS NECESSARY TO GET THE BETTER.
SEVEN BATTERY.
SO YEAH.
HOPEFULLY WILL BE A TEMPORARY
THING HOPEFULLY THEY WILL.
REMEMBER MANAGEMENT -- SEE THE
ERROR OF THEIR WAYS AND THEN.
YEAH SIR TRADING.
GRANDMA WHATEVER A LOT BETTER.
IT'S JUST A AT THE DISCRETION OF
THE COURT RULING [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NOBODY ELSE.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION [inaudible]
SECOND.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER OBERNOLTE WHICH
LED TO CLOSE THIS BILL WILL
SIMPLY GIVE JUDGES MORE TOOLS TO
BE ABLE TO DEAL WITH THIS VERY
SERIOUS PROBLEM AND PROTECT OUR
SENIORS.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE OUT
VERY WELL WE HAVE A MOTION BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO SECONDED
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB THIRTEEN NINETY SIX NAZARIAN.
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I WARNER HARD ROCK.
BORN IN HER ROOM I KALRA.
KALRA I LACKEY ARE LACKEY AYE
REYES.
REYES AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE THE MEASURE PASSES.
IT'S OUT THANK YOU.
SO FOR HOUSEKEEPING [inaudible]
YEAH.
WE READY TO VOTE. FOR THE HOLDS
RECALLS.
OKAY.
OKAY OKAY.
CALL THE ROLL -- WHATEVER IS
SUPPOSED TO DO.
WHAT'S DIFFERENT COMMITTEES ARE
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT [inaudible]
YEAH.
BUT LET'S GET EVERYBODY OUT HERE
THAT WE DID.
AB FIVE SIXTY SEVEN REYES
[inaudible]
REYES I AB ELEVEN THIRTY SEVEN
REYES [inaudible]
RESIGNED.
AB TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN REYES
[inaudible]
REYES AYE. EIGHT THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO REYES [inaudible]
I THANK YOU.
SO WE'RE WAITIN [inaudible]
EXISTING --
RIGHT.
THE RESIDENT OKAY YOU YEAH OKAY
[inaudible]
NEVER KNEW.
BUT IT'S GOING TO MAYOR MILL
.
ALRIGHT SO LET'S SIR.
CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS
WHICH IS BASICALLY ME. FOR ITEM
NUMBER [inaudible]
THREE ROLL CALL.
SB.
FIVE SIXTY EIGHT NAZARIAN HI
NAZARIAN I AND I WERE SEVEN A.
B..
THIRTEEN NINETY SIX NAZARIAN HI
MISSOURI.
NINE FANTASTIC AND WITH THAT THE
COMMITTEE.
HEARING FOR TODAY -- IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU